hello and welcome to
our 2010 meeting live on bs
today is friday january 21st
as usual
allow me to start our
friday announcements with the
president's agenda for next week
monday the president will discuss with
mathias mahora  a German astronaut
who is currently staying on the
international space station
their conversation will be transmitted
live on social networks and I
invite you to discover the details in
our daily news on how to participate
in this event which is
part of the preparations for the next
initiatives of the european union in
terms of space policy on
tuesday the president will receive mr
robert avec vis each vice chancellor
pardon minister of the economy
of germany
on the same day she will also receive mr
camara president of the international committee
of the red cross
still on tuesday  she will also meet
madam anna bernard beach the prime
minister  of serbia
then on Wednesday she will chair
the weekly meeting of the college as usual on
Thursday the president will have an audience
with his majesty the king of the belgians and
finally on Friday the president will chair
the meeting of the high-level round table of
the new european barros so
as  you can see a busy agenda
next week in
vain we have good news concerning nax
general
commission
tourism vidic organized chablis to our
ten actors
gucci
damage to expectations
wright tacot youth employment
ease of access sochaux
he prefers a sign towards
roma
finally for  close announces
allow me to remind you that
today continues the
informal meeting
of environment and energy
ministers meeting which is being held in amiens the ministers are meeting in
joint session today and the commission
is  represented by executive vice president
france thomas mann
commissioner jean loustic avoids chaussée
la com  missaire kadri simpson the
ministers will discuss a
just energy transition and the role of forests
and wood in the
environmental, energy and
climate policies of the european union a
press conference is scheduled
around 5.15 p.m. with the participation
of commissioner sinkiewicz
la  meeting of energy ministers will
continue tomorrow saturday 22 january and
touch and talk about the
current situation including energy prices
energy efficiency and hydrogen
in europe commissioner simpson will
participate in this meeting and the
press conference  which will take place around
3.15 tomorrow so
another informal meeting is being held
today it is that of the
ministers of health of the
european union and the countries of the
european free trade association who are
meeting by
videoconference he is discussing  of the
health situation of
national vaccination strategies and other
measures to combat the pandemic as well as
that of the need to coordinate these
strategies they will also discuss the
question of a fourth dose of vaccine
and the next group purchases of
vaccines the commissioner is she
welcomes to kid s they represent the
commission please note that there will be no
no press conference
following this meeting so here is for
a whole series of announcements we
now invite you to ask your
questions to nawa come back
I thank in this possibility I
would like to ask the question concerning the
reaction of the commission
when iyer the first  minister of
france sir castex announced the
new initiative in france the
government reform at and the
digital pass that ovide which existed before
before for the vaccination pass so
I ask myself the question do
you agree what is the position  of
the commission because madam
president madeleine promised that the
digital pass that ovide will expire on June 30
this year and now it is a
trend which is launched by france which
is the country which presides let us put on the
council of the reformers the digital pass that
ovide in the vaccination pass here I
need your reaction
thank you ana I think that two subjects should not be
confused
the first subject  it is that
of the digital certificate
that ovide that the european union has put in
place and which affects which allows it to
facilitate travel
within europe free movement in europe
and when you talk about deadline
it is in the context of this
discussion, we have always said that the
other health measures taken by the
member states are within the competence of
the member states and it is therefore not up
to the commission to take a position
on these measures and that of course  heard
includes
the use of this
digital european union certificate for
also measures within
member states and our
position on that has never changed so i
'm afraid i have no reaction to  I had to
provide you on this subject
but I was not understandable when
the moment because I listened to Mr.
Castex even twice how we can
now return to France
just intoning the kovy digital certificate which
existed before because there is a
new  rules how these new
rules are going it's coexisted dijon
with the previous rules so it's not
understandable for us is
it understandable for you
it was fine don't think
new and we've already answered
this question a number  countless
fans the fact is that indeed the
certificate put in place by the european union is
only used for one thing to
guarantee free movement within
the european union but then
once a traveler is in another
country  of the European Union
he must of course comply with the
rules of this country and if they are very
strict if it implies I do not know
me that suddenly we cannot  e no longer
going to the stores because a
country has decided to close the stores or
there is a look a year ago we
whatever it is you have to comply with it and so
it applies in the French case
as it  applies on the part of France
but there are other countries which have also put in
place restrictions
regarding, for example, access
to public transport,
the ability to work, therefore to
go to a company, etc.  etc. all of
these are measures that are put in
place by the citizens and citizens
of the European Union people
present in the European Union who
have a European pass to circulate
must of course keep abreast
of health measures  put in place
in the Member State in which they
go and comply with them and that is
absolutely not us and I will stop
there because very sincerely this is a
subject on which we have already
very clearly expressed our  position our
position has  never varied and I invite you
to address and and other questions on the
compatibility between the different
measures to the French authorities
here are there other questions on the
health situation in europe
I see two hands the g in
interactions david
yes thank you eric c  is a flop
because yours our position is very clear
and very simple but after the application
of these rules by the
member states it is quite complicated and it is
even complicated to understand how is
applied in each country  I'll give you a
fairly concrete example
Italy has decided to reduce the validity
of its pass when it passes or as a
certificate that ovide from 9 to 6 months
for people who have not done
a third dose a booster
so
if
and in some countries of the
european union minors under 18
cannot do boosters
so
if i am someone who is going on
holiday a family who is going on
holiday from belgium and is going to italy
for a pass  r the carnival holidays
they will not be able to g2 in a hotel or
go to a restaurant
because italy does not accept any
condition other than the booster
we cannot do
a test even the certificate of recovery
is disputed by some countries
low Italy in this case so here I
understand very well that you have two
different positions one thing is the
European certificate the other thing is
the national passes but there is a
fundamental problem there that there is a
limitation
of the free movement of people
because in the end we can't actually
move around and you say to yourself it's
none of our business
so here's my question 1 firstly
does that pose a problem for you or
not secondly is-  what you
continue to remember that the
member states which require
additional tests etc.
do this in a proportionate way and it is
justified in relation to the
current epidemiological situation I am
obviously talking about free movement in the
sense  strict thank you thank you david your
question nevertheless includes
different dimensions,
one which is on the
additional requirements put in place by
certain member states as to the
conditions for being able to travel between
countries of the European union and
actually fall partly within the competence of
the  european union and on that i can
ask christiane 2
to
answer
game he is connected i think so that's
it so we'll come to him right
away
you know that despite everything we have
always said that we ask we
recommend to the states  members to
coordinate as far as
possible to inform themselves in advance of the
additional measures taken in
terms of health
the requirements is more for travelers
within the European union
with regard to the second dimension, that is
to  actually say the fact
that once you're in another state there
may be
restrictions including 1 pass that's a
question  competence in the area
of ​​health the sharing of competences
between the european union on the one hand
and the member states on the other we can
hope for it to be different but
in the current framework of the treaties it is
the  reality in which
the European Union acts on its side and
the Member States on the other and of
course we can only wish
that there is the best
possible coordination you know that there are meetings
of health ministers
civil servants from the various ministries,
etc. on a very regular basis to
discuss these issues, but during the
holidays the health measures remain
the responsibility of the member states. I
nevertheless come back to the first
dimension of your question, that of
the acceptability or not of the position of
the commission on
driving the additional measures
required by certain member states such
as tests including for people
who hold a certificate that ovide and
i pass the p  arole to christiane on this
subject christian
yes thank you eric thank you and to your question
I may still be able to
buy august been reminded
regarding the issue of
accepting this effective as of february 1
the new rules and regulations
and is in effect for  the nine months
of remote access to
travel and as like eric I think has
already explained
for the rest that it is a
national competence of course to reduce the
divergences and the compression I have the
balls I quote them m also seems
invited to me  to align their rules
for the
national use of the vaccination certificate
on the
seventy-day acceptance waiver applicable in the
context of travel like that is also
something that is discussed in
contexts of the option of  the
update and the free recommendations for these
snacks or
do we explain a very decision will be
made in the next few days
as to the
dishes on and a notification I think
I have d  given a list recently we've read a
little more development for example
funding to sites and
reduce reduce those
restrictions and and we
[Music]
we're happy with that decision
we're
in a situation for a while where
microwaved and all the  europe and the
experts and that includes the beds site here
it is said that the measures
to
have then to save time
are less effective now
that is why we encourage the
member states to
return to a regime
or to the decisions they  have taken in
the contexts of recommendations to
book its collections and to return it
a more coordinated approach
this means
in practice that travelers who have a
vital committee certificate
must talk about submitting on
additional restrictions and it is hoped
the fight that we  will see more
movement in this direction
soon
thank you very much christiane i still see
a question visibly in this
area from my  thieu mathieu
yes hello
it's still on the
delicate freedom between free movement
health protection
for example a person who
certifies that empty in belgium
but who is not vaccinated cerqual
the food with these pcr tests is what
she can
take a tgv thalys train to go
to france from tomorrow or the
maximum pass will be in effect
so a question above
christiane again
ok I hope you understand
understand well
so it's the question if he is
vaccination in belgium accepted in
france that's it i think not the question
it was someone who
lives in belgium who passed we will
say health a health certificate
beh him
by either because this person
finally only because  this
person has taken a test
can she go to france
from tomorrow
given if I understand
the implication correctly it is that in france to
take the train from tomorrow it is
necessary on Monday moreover
he  would have to be vaccinated
so that's then the supplements in
question for the French authorities
for their effect read in detail what the
koubbi certificate does for purse
seiners is obviously
to
give you
proof of test or vaccination
which is going to be at this  which is going to ensure that
your beauty test vaccination proof
and
is correct lastly our hypothetical
and so that's the idea of
this effective quick shot generally it's going to
help you are practically
for jamming
[Music]
generally
the questions in detail  for
for to enter this former country we
must also consult you our
our total highest level for the
gentlemen in place for each country
but what we take I understand your
question matthieu rougé not in mind the
details of all the  announcements that
were made in france lille yesterday it
's something we
can come back to but if I understand
your question correctly it's assuming that it's
the case that in the measures announced
by France yesterday it is said that it is
necessary to have a vaccination pass
so in fact to be vaccinated to be
able to take the train and what
happens for someone who is in a
train which circulates between  the between
belgium and france did
i understand your question correctly
but in fact it is really the question
of the mutual recognition of the
certificate when all the certificates
are identical and no problem afterwards
so there is a vaccination impasse which
reduces  the field of possibilities in france
is that the certificate that ovide
issued in another country will be
recognized by france since it reduces
one of the options that are valid
elsewhere no but that is yet
another question and there the answer  that
christian gave is perfectly
precise
the certificate gives a status it
allows you to prove your status either you
took a test or you are vaccinated you are
a vaccination schedule
with first dose second dose  boost
her breasts either you
are in the period when you are
considered cured of free coc but
still with antibodies so is
this this certificate it is used for
recognition in the context of free
movement within the  europe
then what happens inside the
country and on the basis of this pass is the
responsibility
of its member states so they can
tell you yes you have deadlocked
your step shows that you have
tested you can enter a restaurant
whether or not the pass shows that you are only
testing you cannot go into the
restaurants but that is a
different question compared to that of the
transport
of the free movement
if he has accessed it from another member state I
believe that  'we always have to make
this distinction
mathieu
[Music]
specific to the question
of border crossing and
travel to a country that only
recognizes the no vaccine and
there I told you that
the regulations finally recommend them  So
and the regulations that have been put in place
by the European Union
specify that these are means that are
supposed to facilitate free movement
between member states and here I
refer you to what christian said to 10
previously with regard to
coordination between the member states
in this area there david last
question on the subject
I understand that you are hiding
behind the legalism of perfect respect
for the rules but here we have I mean we
have citizens who probably do
not understand what is going on  passes
because he confuses he doesn't understand
why
if I take a Thalys I can't go
to France if I have a bicycle I can go there
you understand the problem and there are
European countries where you can't ride a bicycle
who must  take a plane and it was not
vaccinated is a certificate co quickly
because you took a test which is negative
you can not go to a country
so that's the whole problem so we
are here we like your answers
precise you point of view of the right but
after there are concrete situations where
the freedom of movement is not guaranteed
you recognize it or not but david
it is all the same
I appreciate your federalism here I am
convinced that there is enormously  of people who
would also appreciate that we have a
European union in
which all of these discussions are
resolved in a
completely harmonized way at European level
is what I understand that the situation
is complicated for the citizens of
the European union of course it is
for you it is for me it turns
out to be changing moving over
time and of course it's a
situation which is complicated for
Europeans is complicated for the
public authorities nobody
disputes it nobody disputes it
but
I reject the fact  that we
demonstrate a kind of excessive legalism,
we happen to be
institutions based on law
and if we do not respect  the law
we reproach them we work
within the framework of our prerogatives the
member states work within the framework
of theirs we make a maximum
of efforts of coordination it is I
remind you in the treaty
the competence of the european union in
these  areas it is a competence of
coordination and we have gone
extremely far extremely far since
the beginning of this crisis in terms of
coordination and this has moreover led
to initiatives
which would have been unthinkable a
few years ago I remind you what
we have done in the field of
the acquisition of vaccines we are trying
to do the same in terms of
coordinating the health measures
taken by the member states and in
particular the coordination of the impact
of these measures on free movement
in the union  European
but it is not possible for us to
take a step which is to say the European Union
asks all the Member States
to do exactly  t the same thing
everywhere it's not it's not
unfortunately I would say within our of
our skills I say this
as a civil servant at the pea but there
are good reasons for that that's what
is  inscribed in the east in the treaties
and we will continue to work within
this framework
within this framework, but once again
making a maximum of efforts so that
the member states coordinate among
themselves, inform each other beforehand
and take into account the difficulties
practices that you rightly point out
that this can generate
for Europeans and in particular
for people living in
border regions and work by
working in these in these regions where
all the people who are required
to move, in particular in a
professional context to  across europe
nobody denies the complexity of the
situation
here
i am going to close this chapter now i
'm sorry it's been already half an
hour that we are on it maybe there is
re other themes so if this is on
another theme and zealand management
tommaso on drugs egan
rights watch voted a movement strike
thank you apologies but
seven days on freedom of movement
in europe because as  you know
the state asks him for a test that quickly
before arriving in the country
until January 31 I know that this
incompetence of the pond and not of the
commission but it is a
serious limitation on the freedom of  circulation is
also it's useless because italy
registered about one hundred and fifty thousand
two hundred thousand new cases that ovide
positive to the day and I wonder if the
commission is
quietly putting pressure on rome because
the measure is over  January 31
thank you thank you we have no
comments to make on christian region
to give all the elements of
response that you we can provide
on the discussions in progress with the
member states on this subject to the last
question  we
ciric but I would like to take
international language because on your site
its brands and which links to 43.10 who
participate and in the
digital pro life pass programs there are also fda
who participate and there are also twelve
other territories countries and territories
so in total we are not only talking
about the European union we are also talking about the
43 countries and no the situation is not
really clear because there is the UPI
France in this case where the new
rules are declared without coordination
with 43 forty two participants in
the project as we have and rx is free
movement how tomorrow people who
do business who have to travel
how they have to deliver there to
go to france this certificate is not
clear it is not always  possible even
because she is on the waiting list
to do the boosters and this is
where I must say that I am surprised that
after months of
discussions here in the press room on
these issues we are still at  this
level discussions
the the program you are talking about is a
program for the technical recognition
of certificates of
electronic solutions set up by one or
the other country
it has absolutely nothing to do with the
fact of saying that the conditions  are
harmonized between the different countries
where we grant rights to the holders
as christian said the certificate is
used to
prove your health status compared
to that ovide and a number of
countries which have set up their own
certificates have seen  the technical nature
is there the ability to authenticate the
health status of people recognized
by the European Union and vice versa
dots
dots that's my answer to your
question
and that's an answer that we
may have already given  a thousand times here in
writing so it's about time that
now we are all able to
understand what is the difference
between the technical nature of the certificate
its role in the circulation at
inside the european union
the role it does not have in relation to the
rights and obligations that gives you in
a country of the european union and the
international dimension these are
different dimensions there is a thread
that connects them  it is that the european union
has put on play on foot with great
success a technical solution which
allows everyone to prove their status and
second great success this has allowed
despite the difficulties that we have
mentioned here on the whole  to
greatly facilitate
movement within
the European Union during a pandemic, there are indeed,
we have always said, moreover, that there
were situations in which the
Member States could take
precautionary measures in the event that the
health situation would require it and
that we encourage them to coordinate the
situation has absolutely not changed
here
you will allow me to
close this chapter now and to open
the debates to other subjects
of the leds
is a
probable causes
thing
[Music]
from the
treaty
non
[Music]
writes david havas and squash christmas think
about it and see
in austria and killed 12 on friday is
smooth and thing
gallery
ten9 al assad continues naughtiness
sponsoring
the
commission response and will not in the
classroom by providing
france under discussion our brands in
mannheim associations the
commission banned bushmen and asia who
opposed switches this press release
was still Monday at football nantes
tip six to ten lengths
here are the two  movements all at brioude
and the guild flots and where odile
yes hello eric I had some
connection problems there during the purpose
of the technical briefing
ensures higher education and I wanted to
know
effectively to attract foreign students
to europe how is it
you
plan both to
curb the disparity in tuition
fees
in different countries and
even within countries  I know that in
France, for example, it's about 230 or
250 euros to enroll in university,
but if you're going to do a master's degree with
the Grandes Ecoles, it can go
up to 15,000 or 15,000 euros,
so  on the one hand the tuition fees
and on the other hand they and some
students are foreigners are
also attracted by the fact that there can
be training in a language they
know and it is often it is
often in  English so on these two
points
what is it there no position
in the strategy for for for for the
universities
I am going to judge I do not understand the second
point the first point I understand is
what we can do
to standardize  tuition fees
within and between the countries of
the European Union I think that on this
we will be able to give you
a fairly clear answer on the
second point on the language I did not
understand odile what he is
what have we done  what are you
asking
what are you asking the
European Union to take into consideration
as long as there is at least some
of the lessons that they are in a
language in a language
that is very widely spoken it is  to say
that is to say in English what do
you see asking what we are going to do
to facilitate or promote
the use of English
in part of the curriculum in the
member states so that students
from elsewhere can study more easily
in the cities the european union
yes indeed that's it or else
can do a little maybe like
the chinese do the chinese and
distributes scholarships to come and do
their medicine in china for example
the african students don't know
concerned don't know  no this will not
necessarily be a chinese word
but it follows must take a
chinese course first before starting
putting their medicine or engineering and
therefore know how to fit in
this conjuncture  international
competition to attract foreign students
to us who we know
can then become very good
relays in relations with
other countries thank you okay I
allow myself it's Friday I want to
allow a little bit
of humor and  as in English we say in
Belgium so if I understand your
question correctly it is that we are going to
favor in one way or another
possibly the learning
of English so that a
Chinese student who wants wants wants  come and
study in france
can take courses in
french universities that would be one of the
possible scenarios
i would be delighted to see what the
reaction of the french authorities at 7 would be to
this suggestion
but on tuition fees i will hand over
to sonia
question
to accomplish
no education then the rhinestones
on european education before 2025 on your
first question regarding
university tuition fees
in europe  it is a competence of the
member states has normally how the
school curriculum at all levels
of education and teaching are
organized it is a competence that is
entirely in the hands of the
member states to the commission has a competence
of the coordination of  support and help
member states to have better
cooperation at European level so
this time we don't have an initiative and
for the moment there are no
projects in this area on
the higher education strategy
what I can say in fact about the
scope because you
also asked that it be the basis of the measures that we have
planned in fact it symbolizes a lot about
transnational cooperation to
really support universities to
cooperate in a more  closer
and more effective for several reasons
and one of the key measures in
this strategy is to increase the
number of European universities to
say alliances of universities
s and it was recommended that
member states support
the adoption of a legal status of these
alliances to allow more favorable access
to the fund and also to remove
the
administrative obstacles for
students also in promotion also
the use of  a European student card
oscillate digital in this
context one and what is
very important is also planned by different funds
in total to support in this
in this financial period before 2027
to support the
universities also in their
research activities  and innovation by 80
billion euros
thank you are there any other questions on
the the strategy that we
recently presented in terms of
higher education for sonia
i can't see are there any other
questions for us  today
daniel
he hello can you hear me go daniel
yes thank you good i will have it's a decision
on the taxonomy
the president of the committee at
the european parliament
of the  environment commission and the
president of the social economy commission
have sent a letter to the
commission asking
you to express their concerns
say that there was not enough
time for exchanges between the
backstage nator he asks for a
public consultation and an elevation
of  'a bape on the inclusion of nuclear
my question is what follow
-up are you going to give this letter thank you a
question for the donkey who is
precisely in strasbourg
thank you with thank you daniel for punta
question indeed I can confirm
that we  have received this letter and
as usual we will respond to
this letter as soon as possible
in general on this delegated act i
think i can say that these topics and
i whose public domain of museums
since
2020 we have consulted and publicly
on  the first delegated acts and i
think on nuclear power you
also know they had a
technical specific process
on the nu  clear
now we are in the process of
consulting the member states of course the
european parliament as well as the
platform on sustainable finance and
after this period of consultation which
ends today in fact at midnight
we will adopt the delegated act as
soon as possible
and  of course we are going to study
the feedback that we receive from the
member states of parliament and so had to
platform and I can also say finally
that
all of us are going that we are in fact
discussing consult the
member states parliament and there was
technical meetings that took place already
this week and last week
daniel you have a follow-up question
we mean by the financial
go ahead no yes we hear now it's
good go ahead
thank you short question of abuse according to
the facts
the  platform experts I mentioned
would have expressed a rather negative opinion
asking for changes by exhuming
this is what the mission is considering
changes who said that  e you go
when you go to examine what
you had but what you envisaged is
what you envisage changes
thank you
daniel it's a good try but as you
know very well
these are not the kind of
questions we answer  we are
of course receiving comments and the
commission will study these comments
before doing that before putting
its proposal on the table, but this is neither the
place nor the time to discuss
the analysis made by the commission of the
comments that  'she can receive
either side
are there any other questions for us
today
from the towns i'm sorry but i have already
answered questions i will not provide
any further information on
the topic you  as you raised you
have the right to ask the question but I
confide continue to tell you that we
think we have
provided all the elements that we
wanted to provide on this subject
here I am delighted to continue to
exchange  r with you bilaterally on the
subject are there any other questions
on other subjects for us today in
lebanon
[Music]
5th game of what i am once towards
the working as from rom as far the
president is  concerned that they offer
the fans the apologies please closely
one of the few of isly contact mr and
especially that in switzerland
a
kashmiri Corsican sorting machine has it warned
[Music]
innobio
acetate and
fears to continue to be you need  to
reason of the niche
0.8 in a win
for party situation with a final the work it is said
that the artillery definitely induces
crisis elis hotels will have to
from 14 years lives happy
frau are
we do not know who this
terrible tsunami will be what  you very good
weekend if on monday